the following is a conversation with
Wasim al-shek co-founder and CTO of
writer
writer is perhaps the best example of a
successful startup delivering on the
promise of generative AI now delivering
over a billion predictions from large
language models every month
with seem and writer have been a long
time user of hugging face a recent
customer and now a contributor of their
own open source large language models
and now here is my conversation with
Wasim al-shek
cool did I sound too much like legs
Highway seem welcome and thank you so
much for joining me for this
conversation
um so I'll jump right into it I live in
San Francisco and every time I drive
down to Silicon Valley I see this
beautiful billboard about writer Ai and
tell me tell me a little bit about your
journey like why did you start a writer
and what's been your journey so far
yeah uh first thanks for for having me
and uh
so it's a it's been a quite quite a
journey you know when you started like
that was basically almost three years
ago was before you know the whole AI
boom that we were seeing today and the
the main focus when you saw about that I
will be thinking about how actually we
if we fixed the main issue creating
content at scale this is how we think
about it how we implement it we think
about content content could be anything
any text you write in any way in any
stuff utilized I think email is creating
content writing slack message replying
to the thread understand it always
coming under the content and when you
start thinking about it more and I think
a creating content in general it's a way
of communication that we have it today
and it's not an easy task it's not like
right content you get the content it's
always around coming from you have a
research you have a bunch of action you
have a lot of tools and flaws around it
you have different type of information
you need to absorb an allies to end up
with the end result that in able to keep
editing and iterate around it so when
you started writer we started basically
how we can actually build tools help
companies
creating content at scale starting with
the marketing and that's what we do
today and then with everything else like
today we have a lot of customer
utilizers not just for marketing for Ops
uh HR Support and even it and legal
Healthcare and fintech use cases
that's amazing and I was so excited to
talk to you because there's so much
activity uh around generative AI that
that became a thing right that became a
big theme uh and out of the whole
landscape writer is really one of those
shiny examples of a real company that
solves real problems for real customers
um I use the app uh it's really a a joy
to use actually I asked the app to uh to
write an intro for you as a podcast
guest uh let me uh let me tell you what
uh let me read what writer wrote
so I asked write a podcast introduction
to introduce Our Guest with seem ashik
co-founder and CTO of writer and writer
uh gave me
um welcome to this episode of the
innovators podcast I'm your host Jeff
Woody and I'm joined today by wesi Magic
the co-founder and CTO of writer with
seam has been has a wealth of experience
in technology having worked at some of
the top tech companies in the world is
passionate about helping individuals and
businesses with their right needs and
has used his expertise to develop an
Innovative platform for writing today
we'll be discussing the Journey of
writer the challenges we seem has faced
and his plans for the future of the
platform so without further Ado join us
as we dive into the fascinating world of
writer that's that's much better than
what I started with
so
yeah I love it so tell me uh tell me how
um how you got from these first steps to
like this amazing experience where you
can just ask a writer anything
uh that's um so how we get that I think
we can always just say that for two
things Transformer
open source community and hard work so
we'll be lucky to have amazing engineer
working with us and we'll be lucky to
have all this Innovation come in the
same time we're living this amazing time
is not just the market and the need
exists also with technology it's crazy
on mind-boggling to me like how much
technology and tools we have access to
and thanks for you know for you guys and
all open source Community have helped us
actually building the tools and
everything we have today so everything
you see today it's it's based on open
source like every without Transformer
will not have our own model that's
answering the system without a lot of
Open Source data that's available in
nettools
so how how we started I remember the
first model we trained was around uh 120
million took us almost six months a lot
of money and struggling with the GPU and
this was three years ago and we could
set a big achievement even the model
kind of we found llm that already can do
is basically simple classification after
a lot of planting
so this is how we started today uh we
but we took this experience and we
learned and we built on top of it and
but today writers basically uh have a
bunch of lnms we we plan more than I
believe we have today around 20 plus
models between the open source and
internally some of them we use some of
them now and those models that uh the
end result of them start start getting
this year by the beginning of this year
uh beginning of this year we start
basically focusing more about instruct
models implementation this is how we end
up what we actually have today in our
website which is you know ask letter or
zero shot implementation
that's really really cool and again like
the experience on writer.com is like
super uh fun uh and easy to use so so
congratulations
um and so you've you've seen the whole
movie uh sort of the the rate of
progress uh of NLP uh and machine
learning
um and as I say like today there is so
much uh frenzy and excitement around
generative Ai and large language models
uh but talking to uh customers users
every day like I see that there are lots
of uh misconceptions out there as to
like how these things work what you can
do with them how you want to make sure
not to use them so I wonder like uh in
your perspective like what are the
biggest misconceptions around today uh
um on generative AI we see they are
going to help human increase
productivities and help them do their
tasks at scale and the big misconception
we see today how people think about AI
going to take my job or replace me we
don't see I want to get there I still
lack in a lot of skills a lot of
implementation negative AI is good for a
demo for the first task but still to put
it at really seat of a human we're not
there yet could be there at some point
but I think we're going to be uh
following from from what we have today
that makes a ton of sense
um and um you know I think we've been
talking for about two years like on and
off
um and to me like it's uh it's so
amazing to see your journey how
um our first interactions were about you
being a user of the platform and
um then we got into uh commercial
relationship where we provide services
to to writer and now uh you're a
contributor uh this past few months
you've been contributing new open source
uh large language models to the
community uh the Palmyra models the the
camel models
um so tell me about uh the models that
you've contributed why you've
contributed them uh and how you think
companies can use them
yeah uh so you know open source for for
us it's it's not a cool thing we do it's
a strategy it's something we believe the
only way to to grow the company and we
and grow the the platform from we want
service we provide today from a quality
perspective performance and more
features is to contributed to the open
source and using open source tools So
based on this belief we think the only
way to to be able to get more from the
open source to contribute to the
community itself
um where we released our first model I
believe we started releasing our model
beginning of this year and we plan we
released around I believe now we have
four or five models the plan actually
before it's the year to release most of
our models to production to to be
available at the hugging phase and also
we all have actually two license making
sure there's really free open source to
everyone to build and utilize the
amazing thing in the last is when we did
it we get a thousand if download or
model we get a lot of feedback positive
feedback and sometimes negative feedback
which is awesome amazing you know
because you can utilize it to learn from
your next training next model next
implementation how you can use it so
producing those those model first we're
getting all this amazing feedback or
learning from the community go back to
work inside you know a black box and the
second things it's getting basically
exposed to what actually people think in
our technology how they could utilize it
and which area we we can actually scale
and improve uh today definitely you know
I recommend everyone to utilize our
model and use them we have smaller model
to publish online with the biggest the
bigger model 20 and 30 billion should be
coming soon and those models as all of
them open source and a battery to
license plus all the data what we use
today is data collected and trained and
cleaned by writer that actually give you
Safety and Security
and you know peace of mind how you could
utilize it in your business at the scale
so I want to win the way we think about
it today like don't you don't need to
use any anything from our work is
willing for us taking our models
implementing in your infrastructure
regardless the open source or the
platform completely it's this is what we
will see we make us actually see what
how we're building value for our
customer or our future customers
that's super super cool and on behalf of
the hiking face Community thanks so much
for contributing these models I think
it's a great examples a great example
for for companies out there to share
their their work and share it in a way
that is permissible right so you're
doing this through Apache 2.0 which is
really really awesome
so I mentioned earlier that uh we
entered into a commercial relationship
and for those who don't know uh hiking
face offers an expert support service
it's called the expert acceleration
program it's how we help companies be
successful with machine learning so we
started that Journey uh a while ago with
you and uh yeah I wanted to get uh your
your thoughts uh your feedback like how
has that been impactful for you and what
kind of companies do you think would
benefit
uh first actually we would love to thank
you for let us be part of the programs
uh you know later today it's still still
small team of Engineers and with all the
advances happening in open source
Community or the contribution and we see
an innovation we see in in hacking face
sometimes it's hard to keep up with it
it's hard to make a decision what you
need to use which utilize which stuff we
should invest in house to build it and
release it which stuff we should do with
me being part of that the program helped
us a lot you know actually working with
with hagging face closely and with your
expertise okay tell us a lot like watch
your stuff maybe is not only ready yet
to be production which is not maybe
writer could work on its solve it and
publish it and give us advice on the
implementation the expertise and the
technical details so you know the
program was very very useful for us
especially the team in our size and help
us a lot scale faster and solve problems
really fast uh one of the story took to
my engineer the other day and they like
without hacking face would be literally
wasting at least three to four months
just researching every year you know
because when he decided to use simple
classifier or like let's use a small uh
maybe to need our own model to use
something like open source should we
spend two weeks testing implementing
researching or we can actually reach out
to hagenfest team can give us a clear
answer help us with the process if you
don't have an answer how we need to
optimize it or utilize anything or even
punch Market implementation so
thanks for you guys let us be part of
this program it help us a lot and it's
gives us a great value
thank you so much Waseem
um and you know I mentioned a writer
today like in the generative AI
landscape it's really a shining example
because it's a real product that helps
real customers do real things and
um that means that you have a lot of
models in production and with many users
using them and every time I've used them
I've got responses suggestions uh come
up really really quick so that must mean
that you spent a lot of energy thinking
about like how to manage the production
of the production side of of machine
learning
and so I'm wondering like can you share
anything on
um what that means for you like how many
models do you need to to serve like how
many requests uh a day or uh do you need
to uh to service
oh yeah so
models we have a lot since you know uh
from like smaller stuff like you know
it could call it classifiers to a few
large language models we serve when I
would actually depends on use cases
today writerself around a billion
billion API call per month and wizard it
around 300 000 word every second
using our online language models wow so
uh and we to do that you know we we
support this with the huge
infrastructures next between actually
GPU and CPU implementation that we have
today
uh
that's super cool uh yeah the the the
cost of running machine learning at
scale can be a really hard uh to uh to
keep the handle on and uh that's
actually one of the
um the main focus of uh our
collaboration at hiking face uh with
Intel uh to make
um acceleration uh and to make it easy
uh to accelerate workloads on CPUs so we
work with them in offering tools to the
community we have an open source package
for that called Optimum Intel where you
can quantize accelerate models and then
run them optimally on CPU so I'm
wondering like is uh CPU usage a big
Focus for you or what kind of use cases
have you found great users for CPUs
uh this is I think one of the you know
every time we build a new service or a
new model the first thing would be like
Steve no the first question will be
Calvin and CPU uh you know running term
for a SAS implementation and especially
for an Enterprise at scale and you know
it's a really really expensive
especially with the GPU and not just
expensive those three is like and also
the resource is limited this is one of
the biggest pain today like can I scale
my infrastructure how much education I
will have in the GPU implementation so
CPU uh it's the ideal solution for us
usually uh we utilize a lot of CPU
augmentation actually one of the biggest
uh utilization of today we used endpoint
to run our CPU our model in CPUs that
that was one of the actually amazing
Services we get from hanging first let
us take our model on it in the CPU with
auto scaling implementation that for CPU
usually we can utilize uh or next to try
to fix stuff between the GPU to CPU
still keep our all large language model
in GPU for batch working just make more
sense and find it hard to take those
models to CPU at this stage but at least
I have four model today running in CPU
at the scale and we'll talk about a
thousands of CPUs wow thousands of CPUs
that's really amazing
um so one thing that came out of out of
uh Intel recently is this new generation
of CPUs called Sapphire Rapids and that
hiking face would be we've been lucky to
get uh sort of first uh Hands-On uh it's
and we found great results Great
benefits for efficiency so probably a
way to save a lot of money and getting
great throughputs for for CPU workloads
so we'll be working hard to uh to make
that available on hiking face inference
endpoints
um and um and uh yeah on onyx runtime uh
as you know we have a lot of tooling
available uh through the optimum Library
where all these acceleration tools
reside so I wonder like for other uh
ctOS or head of infrastructure that have
to deal with like a massive massive
machine learning workloads like you do
like what would be the the main advice
you would give them
foreign
[Music]
we are not in an infrastructure business
you know our our business is talking
about building the model training the
model and delivering to the customer the
best experience and to and it's it's
getting when you go you need to put
everything at the end of this point of
view that means mutualized stuff can
actually help us scale can be cheap easy
to optimize and available at skill so
we're not having issue the resources
we're having issues with deployment this
would make CPU one of the first option
always like any model we have in a train
figure out how we kind of let your CPU
because this actually will be easy to
optimize easy to run we cannot do it
there then can someone else do it on our
behalf of skill like hacking face
endpoint can we deploy it in our behalf
take care of that part we'll do our part
this training building the models and if
that was working in the black can then
actually go from there to actually
someone manage this GPU and the last
option for us will be will be advising
last
take care of everything end to end so
because advice actually focus on exactly
what the value add don't lose resources
and and type just you know and stuff is
not your code for your business
that's super cool thank you so much for
sharing uh wisdom uh with our community
um I really want to congrat congratulate
you on all the success uh of writer uh
it's really awesome to uh to have you as
a user as a customer and now as a
contributor
um so thank you again Waseem hey thanks
so much I think for the cabin as part of
the uh your expert program and you know
we're excited to keep working with you
guys and be part and we are proud to be
part of how you face community
thank you